hello everyone and welcome today we are
catching up on the hogwarts legacy state
of play official gameplay reveal on the
playstation channel this is actually
currently number one on trending for
gaming which is usually full of like
minecraft and roblox and occasionally
fortnite
so i'm surprised that it's popping off
that hard though i am interested in this
game it's not like i'm like
super excited about it but i am
definitely interested in it and excited
to see some actual gameplay to see
what it is um my sister and i played the
crap out of this chamber of secrets game
on pc when we were kids that i loved so
much i doubt it holds up but i was
obsessed with it so
i'm excited to see more i don't know why
i didn't play any of the other games in
that series or if they even exist but i
know i loved that one so
let's do it
make sure that
we 1080 we are okay
like i wonder who the threat's gonna be
i don't even know when it's set or
anything like that i
guess i have a lot of questions that's
what i'm getting at
lumos
in-game footage work in progress footage
feature contains a mix of
gameplay respect the hell out of them
for specifying
what do you think you're doing here
humans
[Music]
interesting
like it's i i'm
interested in the fact that they've
shown us more than just hogwarts there i
really expected it to be like a
school-based game well that is a
hogwarts legacy intentionally showing
beyonce
school of witchcraft and wizardry with a
unique ability to manipulate powerful
ancient magic if it's gonna be like
bullying in the wizarding world you'll
need to cover what's behind the return
of this forgotten magic and who is
seeking to harness it to destroy wizard
kind of threat you may be the one that
decides the fate of the entire wizarding
world they have to stop leaving it up to
children at some point you've got to
someone else has to be making these
decisions
and begin to solve these mysteries you
must create the witch or wizard you want
to be cool
[Music]
i was curious if there would be any
you will meet up with your housemates in
the common room you will then need to oh
my god that's beautiful i just got
chilled some catching do as you were
starting hogwarts late as a fifth year
so you are the new student
you'll begin your studies attending
charms defense against the cause this
looks really good and potions classes i
do like the classes stuff again more
bully where's bully too
pretend this is it class
please welcome the newest rose in our
garden
shall we begin
welcome to year five of chance now this
will be a crucial year what's the
gameplay though
tell me i'm doing these classes but what
am i doing i am confident that we will
take hold with a passion and rigor
requisite of such a challenge
i love it to practice is by dueling
we'll start with youtube
time for a proper hogwarts welcome
uh yeah i guess we'll probably have like
the other kid in school that we're
supposed to hate
classic you may begin
no you are yet
i'm pretty sure you just destroyed that
beginner there's no way that you
is one of the most challenging and
hazardous subjects taught at this school
here you'll meet your professors and
learn to cast spells show me some ui
plants brew potions
you'll be able to explore the castle
famous for its secrets wow it looks good
and mysteries
you'll discover dungeons and secret
passageways
[Music]
you could do some cool puzzle stuff
puzzles that will require magical skill
and a clever mind to solve
that didn't look that hard
you just said accio yeah they even find
yourself in iconic locations you've
never been able to explore before
love loving the density and the variety
of environments is very impressive the
late 1800s so while the common rooms and
classes may be familiar most of your
professors will not be however you may
recognize a few faces
all in good fact once a patrick lets me
join this
jerk ghost peeves
in class and while completing site
assignments that are part of a special
curriculum
yeah with the other fifth years at your
own speed
oh my god i loved the quidditch game
did we get to play quidditch i loved the
quidditch game opportunity on original
xbox so much the area surrounding
hogwarts the magical abilities you learn
to master through your schoolwork will
soon become tested as you unravel a
dangerous mystery by working alongside
the accomplished and yet enigmatic
professor fig to try and discover if the
rumors of a mounting goblin rebellion
hold any weight and if the safety of
hogwarts lies in the balance i have
opinions differ as to how great a threat
really is
well that confirms it then i guess it
seems like the goblins probably are evil
ranrock's loyalists are capable of so
much more than people realize the
wizarding world of this era is fraught
with dangers creatures corrupted by a
magical force power let me see the ui
and sinister witches and wizards all
willing to fight even kill to achieve
their own goals that looks pretty cool
but what happened
there's an uneasy alliance between the
goblins
you said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade that all you
needed was a distraction i gave you a
distraction i just watched a student
take down your destroy you tell them top
hat
is this child you're not telling me but
perhaps you shouldn't involve yourself
with that just yet
i would like to see the ui i i want to i
just want to
damn dude these environments oh thank
you yes good
patience alana
it's a spell that's not accio
we did see lumos as well
apologies
[Music]
enemies possess unique defensive and
offensive abilities
including blasting curses stunning
spells enchanted weaponry and more while
almost looks turn-based
others might enchant and incapacitate
you
mastery of the shield charm allows you
to deflect ranged spells and directions
i really feel like i need to play this
to see what it feels like um
oh that's cool counter attack with
powerful stunning charms allowing you to
follow up with extended spell
combinations
i'm like worried it's going to be like a
little bit too just like
taffy in a kind of dull way like a
mobile game kind of way students who
become particularly adept at spell
casting will find many ways to exploit
their very hard to say i could be
completely wrong
i love the magic and kingdoms of amyloid
so much
and then the first fable that looked
like fable one
[Music]
it could be awesome i just want to i
just want to see the ui or know how i
place slam with descending off
roast with incendio
devastate your enemies using various
finishes
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes
mixing and matching dozens of spells
will let you define your combat style
that could be cool like magicka
on your path to become the only you just
burning people alive here dude
the animation's nice
[Music]
it does look like there's good variety
perhaps you'd be good enough to blast
each other to pieces on your own time
in addition to classes and spells you'll
have access to a deep sense honestly i'm
so stoked about skills the bully voice
progression as a wizard you didn't even
realize how badly i wanted bully to do
decide which talents best fit your play
style to allow you to focus on your
favorite types of magic cool
you can also loot buy or craft your own
magical gear
that will increase your offensive and
defensive capabilities i love crafting
gear can be upgraded and specialized ps4
as well abilities
use a strong even motion when crossing
your ingredients
it totally is gonna be like bully little
mini games
[Music]
for
disposal sure combat as you hone your
one skills you can continue to further
your magical education at hogwarts
progressing your development as a witch
or wizard
brew potions that can increase your
power when you need a boost it's very
witcher
like witcher 2 used to be all about like
don't deploy magical plants to mob the
battle for prepping for fighting
enemies
you can even unleash deadly mandrake
seedlings to incapacitate unsuspecting
enemies
[Music]
in beast's class you will learn about a
variety of magical beasts you might
encounter both at school and as you
explore the world surrounding the castle
and
the goal of today is to remind all of
you how to maneuver on a broomstick
safely oh my god
learning and mastering broom flight is
highly recommended so that you may
travel around the world oh really that
you can just do that do my herbology
homework you're despicable
some abilities may be taught to you by
students who become your friends all of
you to assume i will make friends
develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions
and over time you'll learn their stories
[Music]
cool yeah
this is our chance
i love that accent natsai onai is a
brave adventurer driven by the justice
she seeks
poppy sweeting has a kind heart and
loves magical beasts connecting with
them more easily than with you hello
tiny friends what happens now unafraid
of detention or breaking the rules
sneaking in the restricted section again
is sebastian sallow a charismatic
slytherin we've been over this boy
triple figs cannot reverse a curse with
a troubling family secret nothing can
the sooner you accept that reality the
better you'll meet these students and
more as you expect i wonder if there's
like a choice between classes and
regular gathering areas like if you
choose who you become friends with all
welcome to the room of requirement to
say
one of the most remarkable secrets of
hogwarts is known as the room of
requirement
[Music]
a very smart idea to use the room
request a space that seems to sense what
you need and then provides it for you
what a smart
like gameplay choice what a smart design
choice since you need to catch up to
your peers the room provides space for
you to sew and harvest plants brew
potions and upgrade you oh that's
interesting
man i think i'm probably going to really
enjoy this game a house elf named deke
helps you discover the variants that
allow you to nurture your own menagerie
of magical beasts
beak isn't sure
only one way to find out you can freely
customize this space to reflect your
personality and magical specialties
what
[Music]
oh what the [ __ ] oh my god this is just
like so much more impressive than i
expected journey is available at
hogwarts you'll want to visit the nearby
wizarding village of hogsmeade where
loads of shops and vendors can provide
you with the supplies you require
[Music]
from potion ingredients and recipes
to seeds for magical plants to all sorts
of gear
but hogsmeade also has its dangerous
side a band of dark witches and wizards
emboldened by the turmoil of the times
wander the village outskirts
you must avoid them or defeat them
as you explore you'll find the world i
wonder like how it stops you from just
flying wherever you want wonders
surely it won't do invisible walls
progresses dynamic seasons and this will
fill the sky with lightning like persona
fully meets fable is the vibe i'm
getting wizarding hamlet's pepper the
countryside
each with vendors and residents who have
stories to tell
i'm so into this and missions with which
they could use your assistance
what a fun game to do design on honestly
it may very well have been designed by
merlin himself
when he was a student at hogwarts
magical beasts roamed the lands outside
the castle walls some have been
corrupted by a mysterious dog it's a
really good presentation as well it's
very fast poachers and their trees oh my
god
and restore them to health in the room
of requirement yes
i will amass that all changes
in the world as well dungeons still not
sold on the combat and combat is very
important to me personally
big combat person
be careful where you choose to explore
as it may lead you down a darker path
morality system
befriend new allies journey across a
landscape never seen before uncover
ancient secrets combat mystical threats
learn long forgotten mysteries become
the witch or wizard you want to be
as you leave your unique mark on the
wizarding world
here
in hogwarts legacy damn man
i'm super impressed
wow
[Music]
holiday this year that's this year oh my
god it's 20 22.
damn man okay
so
um
great conference i really enjoyed it um
i want to give the context that like i
grew up with harry potter kinda in the
same way everyone else did um
interestingly they were pretty similar
ages to me i think so
read all the books when they came out
and then went and saw the movies in
theaters so it's like yeah i absorbed
all of that when i was younger but i
don't feel like i'm like a hardcore
harry potter fan like some of the other
people i know like
definitely
did all of this stuff
um
but don't pay a lot of attention harry
potter now
and so
that didn't appeal to me in like a harry
potter fan way um not that i'm not it's
just like i'm not more than anyone
else's
uh it definitely appealed to me in a
video game way like you could remove the
hogwarts from it and i'm still into that
which i didn't expect definitely want to
see how the combat is because
yeah i mean
magic based combat can be so cool but it
can also be really rough so i'm just i
would love to see the ui to know how
that actually feels um
but the world looks awesome like damn i
did not expect to be as hyped about this
as i am now but i looked really good um
i guess also worth noting of course
before i finish this video
obviously
uh jk rowling
created harry potter and
is pretty transphobic uh and i obviously
do not support that especially like
sucks right now there are actual
legislations that are making it more
difficult for trans people to even
really exist and it's very [ __ ] up
i'll leave a link in the description to
your resource for if anybody needs any
help
um
i wish i could do something else um
but i don't
think that boycotting this game would do
anything to help
the trans community it is more likely to
hurt uh
the devs really um that's kind of how i
feel about that is like i don't support
jk rowling she's one of the only people
that i have like her name even muted on
twitter because i just
i don't want to see it anymore you could
just you could just chill out you could
just stop speaking that would be awesome
so i just opted out of that
but i don't feel the need to opt out of
of hogwarts legacy um but of course i
could be completely wrong about that my
take could be incorrect i just it
doesn't feel
like the dev team working on this game
uh who have made something that i think
looks really [ __ ] cool should be
punished for her actions when it's not
even hers anymore so
uh curious to see what the internet
thinks shall we have a look at some
comments
well this actually looks like it's gonna
be a lot to do i'm excited me too
everything i'd won out of a harry potter
game same but more
yeah seem really positive environment
design looks gorgeous
totally agree writing surprisingly
developed don't know about that yet
yeah
rather fun the chamber secrets me too
this person gets it loved that game
however i enjoyed the mechanics of hp7
have not played it this new game seems
to immersive and massive interactive
environment i'm stoked
i am also hoping we get a pet i had that
thought too
can't believe this is all one game
yeah i agree this was a really really
really good conference um they did a
really good job
i am curious again if that morality
system is going to be like that where's
peter mullin you
dev's really said we're exceeding every
expectation with this game and i'm too
some speak i agree i'm i'm glad
everybody seems to be on board
i was worried this game is going to be
super one-dimensional looks like i have
nothing to worry about i wasn't
expecting this much call way to give it
a try totally agree
this looks awesome i'm now very very
excited about it whereas i think at the
start of this video i was like you know
kind of interested whatever i'm now like
dude
this looks rad very very very excited to
play it i guess at the end of this year
thank you all for watching and we'll see
you guys next time bye